you knew this was coming pete oh oh
yeah you knew phil theory was gonna come
out one of these i've been waiting for
it all right so we got from film theory
matt pat and the gang three new
spider-man no way home theories when i
say i've been waiting i've talked with
one of the editors like when's matpat
gonna come and he didn't give me a heads
up you son of a bee let's do this
[Music]
be careful what you wish for parker
hello peter all right anyone see
anything new this time
could be a felicia hardy clue you know
the black cat i think we noticed that
around past number
246 then no maybe we do another round at
0.75 speed you ever wonder whether we're
starting to miss the forest for the
trees on these things you mean apart
from being in a video production bunker
all day and thus seeing neither forests
nor trees no no no i mean like sure
there are easter eggs in the trailers
they get paid off later but i mean
really how deep does the rabbit truly go
really thinking this hard planning all
this out or is it just us speculating
grasping at straws just looking for the
next little detail that we can
desperately cling to in order to claim
another 15 minutes of relevance are we
just wasting our lives watching the
spider-man trailer 300 times
every last detail what's today's date
again august 23rd
why
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
i just gotta say that was probably the
funniest intro that i think they have
done so far holy crap that is pretty
much everyone on the internet who does
spiderman no way home videos and i just
love the touch and he touches how
exhausted and tired he looks the whole
time i had some great commentary great
great commentary this is going to be a
good one hello internet welcome to film
theory the show that knows you'll always
find your way home to our like and
subscribe button speaking of likes holy
cow did people like that spider-man no
way home trailer in 24 hours the thing
amassed a total of
355 million views annihilating the
previous record holder avengers end game
with its mere 298 million and it's not
hard to see why a new spider-man sequel
is in a pedigree by itself it's not a
prequel about a character who's already
died it's not an origin story for a
character no one's ever heard of it's
not whatever eternals is trying to be
which gotta be honest they're at the
final trailer stage and i still don't
see any semblance of a story there none
of those things instead it's the payoff
to one of cinema's greatest most recent
cliffhanger starring the most beloved
marvel superhero of all time that alone
has got to get people more excited than
tim burton in a spirit halloween store
then add to that a potential multiversal
crossover with resurrected three disney
villains and classic spider-man and yeah
you got something that's gonna make
thanos numbers look like
you know that if toby mcfarland
one moment of them doing the spider-man
point at each other and the internet
will melt literally just pull up and
melt on the floor it'll be the greatest
missed opportunity if they don't do it
even if it's not in the actual movie but
if they do it like in a mid-credit scene
or a postgres and let's say they have
one of those mid credits postgres is
just like kind of funny and not really a
setup you gotta do it you just have to
do it you know you have to you got it
that's the fan the only piece of fan
service i expect here's the other thing
everyone in the blog is fears for
getting into the spider verse yeah
that's also a sony property spoiler
alert there's absolutely a 100 chance
that miles morales and a spider-verse
reference will appear in this movie what
i'm really hoping for here is that
there's a fully animated segment within
this film but either way you don't just
waste time promote your other massive
spider-man property about multiversal
crossovers within this movie about
spider-man and multiversal crossovers
anyway now that we've all seen it or i
guess i shouldn't say all but again
355 million people in 24 hours is about
as close to all as we get in terms of
unifying experiences outside of course
like the planet exploding or i don't
know the mcrib coming back a lot of us
have also noticed that something feels
kind of off about what's actually
happening within this trailer like why
would a fugitive peter parker wanted for
murder actually go back to his high
school why is it snowing indoors why is
dr strange lying to wong about a
dangerous spell and when did flash
thompson get that die job not so much
that the apparent sequence of events
don't make sense it's that the actions
of the people making them don't seem to
align with how we necessarily expect
them to act something is going on here
there are already a ton of interesting
theories circulating is dr strange being
manipulated is he a variant from another
universe is this some kind of it's a
wonderful life fake wish fulfillment
dream scenario to teach peter
why he's wrong to turn to magic to solve
his problems or is this the evil doctor
strange from episode 4 of what if who is
also secretly mephistic break it down
matpat
i think all of them are actually hitting
pretty close to the truth and we'll talk
about them all here in a minute but i've
also got a theory that looks just a
little bit further my spider sense tells
me no way home isn't just a huge
spider-man sequel it's also setting up
yet another spider-man reboot okay so
for this theory to make any sense okay
do you even know why they're called
trailers they're shown in front of
movies after all so what's the deal they
used to be in that whole business of
advertising movies has changed a lot
over the years back in the really early
pre-television days when going to the
movies was an all-day event studios
would show two of their movies in a row
back-to-back with the lower budget less
well-known one going first this was the
origin of the term b-movie bees have
never been afraid to change the world i
mean what about b columbus be gandhi for
jesus
railing the preceding show hence the
term trailers but their goal has and
will always be selling the audience on
the next big upcoming movie and the one
technique that's proven more effective
than any other is building a sense of
mystery no joke we think of this as a
fairly recent trend but check out this
old trailer from the movie psycho where
the director alfred hitchcock just walks
you around the set and makes everything
into a cliffhanger a quiet little motel
perfectly harmless looking when in fact
it has now become the scene of the crime
oh by the way
this picture has great significance are
you teased
it goes on like this for six minutes
nowadays things are a little bit fancier
than this with digital editing allowing
studios to fake entire scenes just to
get that trailer narrative that they
want in the trailers for infinity war
they created a team shot with the hulk
that was never in the movie they changed
the number of the stones in the infinity
gauntlet so people wouldn't know which
order the scenes took place in i mean
sure this fight on the train from the no
way home trailer looks like spidey's
fighting doctor strange but maybe
they're both fighting someone who hasn't
been added to the finish
is still at large he dresses pretty much
like strange does so it wouldn't be that
tough of an edit to deep fake out same
thing with this woman who awkwardly
looks pasted in there and doesn't move
it could be some spidey sense slow down
effect or maybe this is just a stand-in
pasted in over someone who might have
been an actual spoiler the point is well
yeah doctor stream how crazy would that
be
i feel like so many of these shots have
to be tampered with want more context in
reality we don't have any context for
any of this it just feels like we do
because the trailers editing did a great
job using a story structure to sell a
micro narrative about the general
premise
as much of the premise as they want us
to be aware of right now i can
practically guarantee you that doctor
strange's lying about the dangers of
messing with the multiverse comes from
probably the final minutes of the movie
what we do know is that peter's secret
identity was revealed at the end of far
from home it's messing up his life and
the lives of his loved ones and so he's
asking dr strange to mind wipe the
planet and if you know your spider-man
comics well that premise is going to
make you sit
upright
one of the most controversial spider-man
story arcs of all time one more day i
have a feeling i know where he's going
with this i'm just gonna try to make a
prediction upon matpat's prediction
let's see if i end up completely wrong
okay okay he's talking about like
another reboot now i've been hearing
rumors circulating that they are gearing
up for trying to go for another sinister
six movie again not the drew goddard one
but a different one i know a few people
who believe they might have like an
actual spider-man 4 already in
development with a three spider-man but
especially with referencing one more day
one more day was used because oh i'm
forgetting the editor-in-chief at the
time my god you guys know it tell me
down below he thought like we need to
reboot spider-man and one more day was
had severe backlash in terms of how they
retcon so many things but a big part of
the motive to do it was to reboot
spider-man once again so to be borrowing
from one more day that a lot of these
references that you're seeing in the
trailer alone i could see how a reboot
would line up considering that they are
borrowed from it the suspicious part is
like it's already going so well so maybe
perhaps they're going into the path of a
reboot because sony's seeing all this
potential with spider-man they just
renamed it to like the sony spider-man
universe so i think they're trying to
get to a point where they can just have
tom hall and spider-man back to
themselves and they could do whatever
they want with him and not be so much
mcu associated so that's why i think a
reboot might be in the works if that's
what matpat's getting at we'll see
originally published in 2007 one more
day was part of the aftermath of civil
wars storyline where just like it
appeared in the movies the team fights
over whether superheroes should have to
register themselves in order to protect
the public in the comics heroes who
initially supported iron man's
pro-registration team had to publicly
reveal their secret identities as part
of the agreement so peter being on team
stark is something that he almost
immediately regrets and that my friends
that's why you always have to read the
fine print and since every villain now
knew how to find spider-man ant-may
catches a bullet from a hitman lapsing
into a fatal coma brought on by her
injuries and you know probably being
like 1000 years old at this point after
going to everyone he knows to try and
fix it including doctor strange he gets
hit up by someone who says that they can
help mephisto aka the devil who offers
to infernal magic ant-may back to life
provided peter allows him to erase the
other thing spider-man loves the most
the entire history of his marriage to
mary jane watson something which
wouldn't you know it marvel's editors at
the time had also been trying
unsuccessfully to erase for over a
decade spider-man says yes and he and
mary jane are allowed to be together for
one more day that's the name of the
movie and then peter wakes up in a
rebooting
surprise
and yeah this story is one of the
reasons why so many people are always
looking for mephisto to show up this
time with no way home well yeah the
mephisto theories really seem to fit the
broad strokes of the story work it's
gotta say i just love it when big
youtubers we follow reference other big
youtubers who we watch right we're
literally kids where's that next pitch
meeting collab matt pat where's that
comment the crossover we didn't know we
needed the broad strokes of the story
work peter wants the world to forget his
identity he makes a deal with a magic
user chaos ensues then of course you
have the smaller details like the guy
holding up the devil horns caricature of
peter parker in the protest scene with
the text that reads devil in disguise i
mean that's not even trying to hide it
at this point i think that marvel knows
that every trailer they release needs a
mephisto easter egg and not that but
this theory would also explain all the
weird stuff happening with doctor
strange in the trailer you see in
episode 4 of marvel's what if we're
introduced to an alternate version of
doctor strange nicknamed armani come
this way sorcerer armani and labelled in
the subtitles as strange supreme in this
episode he attempts to use the time
stone to save his love christine who in
this timeline died in the accident that
broke strange's hands from the original
mcu we're told that the moment of her
death is called an absolute point
something that cannot be changed because
doing so would create a paradox her
death
is an absolute point in time
absolutely unchangeable his
transformation at this point is uh
fairly demonic someone even goes so far
as to call him the devil eventually he
becomes powerful enough to shatter the
absolute point except there's one
problem like breaking a load-bearing
beam in a house demolishing that moment
in time causes the universe to collapse
around him as strange supreme struggles
to keep the universe intact the very
fabric of reality crushes him into a
small purple jacket what a great episode
you're thinking so what matpat this
sounds like a complete story alternate
universe doctor strange destroyed his
own universe out of arrogance story
closed right true not right theorists
for one we hear this line at the end of
the spider-man trailer be careful what
you wish
it's a warning that would believably
come from a doctor strange who just
wished to have his love back and
sacrificed his soul and entire universe
to get in only for that to backfire
horribly also notice how no way homes
doctor strange still wears the eye of
agamotto something that oh i don't know
thanos destroyed back in infinity war
now who has an intact version of that
charm
and what if and the similarities just
keep going wong in the what if episode
gives a warning that strange immediately
ignores pretty much paralleling the
exact same scene in the spider-man yeah
yeah yeah i'm going to start the kettle
i suggest you join me before you do
something reckless what i've been saying
and i said this a lot in the trailer
talk live stream that maybe we might see
two doctor strangers in this movie maybe
the one we have been looking at is
strange supreme this whole time or maybe
we are with just regular doctor strange
and then strange supreme comes into the
fold we know
that doctor strange has the capability
of containing the spider-man villains at
least that's what been reported on a lot
in some type of prison that he has so
maybe he has strange supreme in some
kind of prison or something like that
but i don't know what it would be bottom
line what i'm trying to say is that i
feel like it's probable that we could
see two doctor strangers in this movie
one being the one from the what if and
then one being the one that we already
know maybe they have the gems somewhere
in the sanctum or whatever and at the
end of what if strange supreme cries out
to uwatu the watcher to do something
showing that this version of strange is
powerful enough to see and talk to an
interdimensional being but uwatu claims
that he can't help the guy because do
and so would endanger all other
universes this proves that if armani
escaped his purple gem prison he would
have the knowledge and ability and
motive to tamper with the very fabric of
reality exactly what strange is doing in
the no way home trail
all of it is without even going into how
having a demonic doctor strange filled
the role of mephisto would help
introduce the character while also
circumventing china's heavy censorship
around the devil and a cult something
that we talked extensively about in a
previous one division episode linked
right meow so this has got to be him
right the devil himself mephisto finally
steps out from the mcu shadows set up in
an alternate timeline presented in
what-if chaos launched spider-man into a
multiversal war against his greatest
enemies and um and uh what exactly you
see that's the problem with the whole
strange isn't himself theory train that
i've been seeing going around it's too
complicated spider-man is too mainstream
of a character and too important of a
franchise to get bogged down with things
having to be set up in a disney plus
series the offshoot franchises have to
be in service of the movies not vice
versa we can't set up a multiverse and
multiple enemies and multiple spider-men
and also dr strange actually being the
devil all in this one movie it is just
way too much plus you don't even have to
go that far there's a better fit for
this story found in the comics one that
doesn't require mephisto and one that
quite honestly more closely follows what
we see happening in the trailer i don't
know why no one's brought this one up in
public discourse yet but the clear
parallel to the story in no way home
isn't one more day it's the story's
follow-up the lesser-known one moment in
time now people don't tend to know this
one because one more day was so
unpopular that a lot of fans refused to
acknowledge anything that came after it
in the timeline but stop me for a minute
if any of these plot points sound
familiar after peter parker's identity
gets out his family and loved ones are
suddenly put into danger and he goes not
to mephisto but rather to dr strange for
help asking strange to erase the world's
memories of his identity as spider-man
to quote from the comic i blew it
strange i put my family in the
crosshairs i need the world to forget
that i'm spider-man strange then
disappears to think it through just like
in these shots from the trailer after
consulting with mr fantastic and iron
man doctor strange agrees he creates a
protective bubble for peter to be
shielded from the spell and starts his
magic and oh wait wouldn't you know it
peter starts having second thoughts
regrets his decision
this is it right here
causes chaos so to recap we've got
ourselves peter asking doctor strange to
do a memory scrub and then changing his
mind mid abracadabra because he's torn
about losing his loved ones sounds like
we might have found ourselves the real
source of this story in the end mary
jane is like you should have let me
forget too and tldr the lesson is that
peter needed to grow up and not rely on
magic to solve his problems to quote
from the story i should have listened to
doc strange when he told me there were a
lot of things he could do with his magic
but i didn't and he was right in the end
i just needed to grow up and face the
inevitable which to me sounds exactly
like the moral of a spider-man growing
up yeah
and to get there you know he just needs
to hop between a few different universes
to talk to older wiser spiderman who've
been in his shoes before i mean i feel
like matpat hit the nail on the head
there the whole thing about uh moment in
time being the one that it's drawing
mainly from one more day was
significantly more popular because of
what it represented in this comic book
zeitgeist at the time for the medium the
amount of discussion around it about
discourse around it
yeah was a big part of why that comic
was was so massive i'm not familiar with
the moment in time to be honest like one
more day yeah but moment of time i'm not
to be seeing that parallel i'm like oh
wait this parallel seems to line up and
what happens in one more day it's kind
of similar setups for sure especially
with there being like what he brings up
here where there being a thematic
spider-man lesson and then also if
you're bringing in the other spider-man
to learn the wisdom from them like have
this peter who is growing up having to
deal with the consequences and realize
it's just a part of becoming an adult
with your identity exposed i think
that's a much better parallel to draw
and especially because spider-man
generally is his character who yeah has
a secret identity if you're just within
the spider-man context but he's thrusted
into the mcu world where so many of our
superheroes identity is rev is known to
the public it's huge because he's a
teenager he wants to protect people i
get it but with this spider-man being in
the mcu i don't think the consequences
of him to having his identity out there
is as massive because of the fact that
we've already got so many superheroes
whose identity is already known to the
public you know what i mean yeah i mean
the major difference is just that he
lives a more street level life so
yeah
it's easier to access him or whatever
but if he had tony stark money he could
live in a safe place where probably this
wouldn't matter very much i don't get
why he doesn't have tony stark money
he's able to build these awesome web
shooters and he should be able to help
buddy yeah
hey that was actually that was actually
a point that toby maguire brought up a
long time ago about why he didn't like
the idea of web shooters because he's
like why would he need to do photography
if he's that involved he could just be a
professional
but wait there's one final universe that
we've neglected to mention in this
entire theory and that's ours and this
is where the reboot stuff comes in you
see the world seems to have forgotten
that disney and sony still have an
awkward step step-parent relationship
with spider-man sure disney may have
convinced sony to give him streaming
rights to spider-man through 2026 but
what about the other deal the one where
sony still owns the movie writes to all
of spider-man but they co-produce the
main ones with marvel studios so they
can be in the mcu as far as anyone
saying publicly that's apparently still
set to expire when tom holland's current
contract for this solo movie as well as
one more yet unknown marvel appearance
included which means one thing it's
quickly becoming renegotiation time and
that means there's always a chance that
sony decides to take its web covered
ball and go home which brings us to our
other theory today whatever happens in
spider-man no way home whichever other
villains show up whichever other
spider-man appear by whatever means
wanda maximoff zaps in during the
post-credits scene
for the multiverse of madness this story
is going to wrap up in such a way that
while there can be a path forward for
tom holland's peter parker he can also
be soft rebooted as a different peter
parker or heck a different spider-man
like miles morales if and when things
between disney and sony don't go well i
mean you think it's just a coincidence
they chose to go all in on a premise
that's based on two comic story lines
that literally were created to reboot
the character consider this peter says
that he wants the world to forget that
mysterio revealed his identity but
immediately interrupts the spell to
preserve certain memories for certain
people it's clear that what he really
wants is the opposite of that famous
uncle ben line to have the power of
being spider-man without the
responsibility that comes with it he
wants to be spider-man but also wants
personal connections that aren't put at
risk just like peter did in one moment
in time and also in sam raimi's
spider-man 2 and also again in amazing
spider-man 2. tom holland in this movie
is going to have to learn that you can't
have it both ways he's going to have to
make a choice
is you trying to live two different
lives the longer you do it the more
dangerous it becomes he'll have to give
up one part or the other of his double
life and the thing about that is
basically any decision he makes in that
scenario in any direction completely
upends the spider-man status quo staying
as spider-man and memory wiping everyone
well that turns every character
relationship into a clean slate moving
forward as spider-man without a memory
wipe he's gonna have to distance himself
from his loved ones because they're now
in danger giving up the mask entirely to
someone else so he can live a normal
life with his loved ones yeah that's big
reboot time i'm sure you all can think
of more than that but what all those
scenarios have in common is that they're
open-ended and reboot ready if sony or
disney start having second thoughts
about the joint custody agreement the
bottom line is this in order for this
story to conclude in a satisfying
impactful definitive way that also
leaves the franchise able to proceed
spider-man himself is gonna be the one
who can't go back to the way things were
whose only choices will be to go forward
into a radically changed world in the
end it's peter who'll truly have no way
home but hey that's just a theory a film
theory and cuts
that was awesome damn dude that was
comprehensive yeah obviously we fought
so many theories and stuff like that
that some of it is a hodgepodge of
things that we've heard before but he
also brings up a lot of excellent points
that we've already touched on i think it
really hit the nail on the head that one
moment in time you guys subscribe to
film theory if you haven't done so
already they hit 10 million subs i'm
really happy for them to get them to 11
million subscribe to real rejects click
that notification bell hit that like
button thanks so much for being here and
hey we'll catch you guys soon
you